let me let me start there with chris
mannix who joins us now in the bubble
sports illustrated nba senior writer
was that a makeup call uh on the greek
freak with uh jimmy butler
i don't know if it was a makeup call you
can certainly
argue that it was given it was the exact
same referee
that made that call um and you can
certainly defend
the legality of the call and i think you
will see that defended in the last
two-minute report that comes out
later this afternoon but i mean those
are two calls that
i think you you put your whistle in your
pocket in those situations i mean i
understand
on the first one you've got to let a guy
land this has been
something the nba has called
consistently it dates back to
when kawhi leonard got injured a few
years ago uh
by stepping i think it was zaza pachulia
stepped underneath him the nba is very
specific on making that particular call
but the second one
i mean you had another referee dan right
there five feet away
and he doesn't make the call i i just
don't i mean the makeup call is a very
sensitive thing to nba referees i think
it was
was it 2011 when a referee actually sued
a reporter
for tweeting about a makeup call
tweeting you heard something
about a makeup call uh so this has
always been a sensitive topic but it
certainly
yeah i think it was bill spooner back in
the day you have to look that up but it
was it was uh
there's something the league is very
sensitive and i understand it that
as a shooter when you go up you you'll
see guys
they used to just put their foot
underneath you just to have you
think of something other than taking
that shot like now i got to worry about
coming down
chris middleton is jumping into goran
dragach's space
so he's initiating that and that's why i
wouldn't have given him the benefit of
the doubt there
and i wouldn't have called the foul on
the greek freak um you know i
i hated to see it come down to something
like that uh
but here we are with the miami heat up
two games to none how much trouble
is milwaukee in right now oh an enormous
amount of trouble i
i mean look there are all sorts of
advantages miami has had in this series
but i think eric spoelstra has been
masterful
in this series you watch these two games
and and i've been there for them and
it just seems like miami is a step ahead
of milwaukee on
everything they can anticipate what
milwaukee is going to do
offensively defensively they're
exploiting every weakness
that the bucks have their shooters are
playing with enormous confidence jimmy
butler most of the time
looks like the best player on the floor
i'm with you dan
you've got to play yana's 40 plus
minutes in these next few games
what are you saving it for at this point
i had a coach talk to me about something
that fits into this just the other day
we were talking about boston now
boston's
you know 6-0 now and one of the things
that coach said was like you know the
celtics don't have great depth
but what do you need great depth for in
the playoffs like in the regular season
depth is awesome like you can play you
you go 910 deep in the playoffs you
really only need to go seven deep and
play your guys extended minutes
uh to get wins and the bucks gotta you
know throw their depth
out the window and just play their best
guys as much as possible if they won't
have any hope
of getting back in the series uh who's
in more trouble the raptors or the bucks
i think the bucks are um only because i
think the raptors have a certain mental
toughness that developed last year
that will allow them to bounce back and
look game two
was lost because marcus smart went
berserk like how often
are you really going to expect marcus
smart to have five three-pointers
in a three-minute span i mean their
raptors weren't pretty much controlled
there
uh so i think their mental toughness i
think you know i've written this a
couple times like kawhi leonard is gone
but kawhi leonard is still there with
the raptors he taught them a lot about
how to shake off losses
and just you know put it aside and get
back and get out there playing the
question for the raptors though
is when is pascal's yacht going to show
up for this
he has not he has not been the syakum we
saw
pre-pandemic uh in this restart i mean
the the regular
the seating games he shot the ball
poorly he had i think only one game in
the first round
where he shot better than 43 i think he
had only
what two points on free throws in the
fourth quarter of game two
you know nick nurse has told me like
this this is the guy we need to make
plays for us
in end-of-game situations you can have
all the the quality shooting you want
with lowry and vanvleet and anobi and
all those guys
at some point somebody's going to make a
shot for you and ciacom
has been billed as that guy he hasn't
been that guy up to this point boston's
got like three of them
that can make shots for you in those
situations ciaco's the one guy toronto
has
he hasn't done it yet rockets thunder
the rockets survive
uh james harden uh his defense helps the
rockets move on to face the lakers
uh what do you take what's the takeaway
from rockets thunder
i tell you sitting courtside last night
like
towards the end of the game you could
almost like feel the sizzling hot
rockets takes like enveloping you like
people like
james harden uh mike d'antoni's fire
russell westbrook and russell westbrook
could have gone for 40 20 and 20. it
would have been
all his fault in this game like if you
could just feel
the criticisms boiling over okay but if
george hits that shot though chris
what are you saying today about the
rockets
i'm saying it's i mean look dad i wrote
half the column so i can go find it if
you want like it's just
i have the hot stakes too like it's
right you should post the half the
column you were writing if the rockets
lost last night
you write the topper and fill in the
quotes
uh you probably look mike d'antoni would
have been
gone out the door uh you probably would
have had
and you may still have a discussion
about trading james harden down the line
i mean if
if they had failed in the first round
and not just failed the first round
but failed in the first round to a team
that they dumped their other star
player on this past offseason i mean
chris paul
had not to change the topic here but
chris paul i mean
you talked people in the oklahoma city
organization like chris would never
admit it but like
he could taste this like he wanted this
as bad
as any series i think he's ever played
it and you know i don't know what the
dynamic is between paul and hardin you
know behind the scenes but
you know at the end of the game paul you
know hugged russell westbrook for a good
five or six seconds
he basically tapped james harden on the
side and the way out the door
and said goodbye there so there's
there's a strange dynamic there
the rockets though you know they lived
to fight another day but the
the franchise i think it would have been
shaken up
significantly i think you would have
seen at least one blockbuster deal how
could you
trade james harden how i mean boss you
can trade anybody
how could you trade chris paul like
chris paul no chris paul is at the end
of his career
no but like what do you say i mean i'm
saying like
you might be asking a different question
like i'm saying how do you trade a guy
with that big contract
you can trade any kind of contract you
want i think there would be a market for
okay james i think it would have been a
handful of teams out there
you could always turn to the knicks and
ask them
[Laughter]
all right let's look at the match-up for
the uh lakers here with the rockets
uh and i thought that the rockets had
the higher ceiling
uh you know with the thunder and the
rockets a higher ceiling
uh you know there are times when their
basement is a lot lower
so i don't know what we're going to get
the lakers probably don't know what
they're going to get here so how would
you handicap this matchup between these
two
what it boils down to for me is a lot of
what
the lakers blazers first round series
boiled down to and that
is for the rockets to have any chance of
winning um
you have to have the most dominant
performance ever by hardin westbrook
like they have to
average between them 55 to 60 points
uh 10 to 20 assists and they've got to
shoot
you know 35 plus percent from three and
45 plus percent from the floor
i mean that's their only advantage i
mean the rockets when they start
game one tomorrow like their tallest
player might be like the fourth tallest
player on the lakers like it's gonna be
such a weird
dynamic out there with the super-sized
lakers versus the super small rockets
and look they've won games i think the
in the seating games milwaukee i
rebounded them by like 30. so they've
won games where
they've been crushed on the boards
they've just had to make threes
at a historically high level so they're
probably going to put up between 50 and
63s per game
in this series they've got to make 35 40
of them and
and hardin and westbrook have to be a
huge part of that
nuggets clippers what do you expect out
of this
i like the clippers reasonably
comfortably um
i've long believed and i've said this i
think to you before the clippers the
type of team
that is going to significantly improve
every single game
because you saw what they were in the
seating games desperately trying to get
all nine of their rotation players on
the floor montrez harrell
just got back for game one of that last
series and you saw them get
progressively better they had their laps
of course paul george stunk it up in the
first few games
and luca doncha just went crazy in a
couple of them but i liked what i saw i
mean kawhi is playing at
at a kawhi like level and i just think
the
the way the matchups play out with kawhi
and paul george
able to match up with jamal murray
they've got some bodies you can throw at
at nikola jokic as well
but nuggets are gas too dan i mean i
went to their practice yesterday and
there was open grumbling
about how they have to turn around after
a seven game series
and play the rested clippers you know 36
hours later
or whatever it was i i just don't know
how much the nugget's gonna have left in
the tank
to play a team this deep and this
talented like l.a mclovin brought this
up about 20 minutes ago and he said
you know why don't we wait until the end
of the postseason to name the mvp
but i mean for just the mvp or all the
awards
i mean where are we dividing the line
mclevin where are you dividing the line
here
why not all the awards because some guys
might not be eligible pearl off like if
you don't if
if you if you have like the sixth man of
the year that's on a team that didn't
make the playoffs are you going to give
a playoff team the benefit of four or
five more games for their guy to
sway voters i mean that's that's part of
it it's a regular season award
i think i i think the awards process
will survive if the washington wizards
six man
gets robbed of an award bc didn't make
the play all right all right well
brandon ingram brandon won most improved
player this year i mean what if they had
the playoffs and bam adebayo
who came in second place had the benefit
of you know two rounds or three rounds
or whatever it was i mean
i can't give brandon ingram most
improved if you're i didn't either
overall nope no no
you can't be a lottery pick and be most
improved player we disagree on a lot but
on this one we are in lockstep
like it is insane to me when i look at
that voting i look at that voting and i
see brandon ingram and luka doncic in
like the top four
like what are we doing here these are
guys there's one that was compared
favorably to kevin durant
and one who in his rookie year was being
called like the next great international
player
one of the greatest international
players of all time for me
it's bam out of bio i voted for davis
berton second because he came out of
nowhere after being traded from the
spurs
basically dumped onto the wizards he got
there and then uh
uh devonta graham who was a second round
pick with charlotte like he
made a big splash this year that's
better that's that's what it should be
it's insane to give
top three picks the most improved player
is billy donovan
staying in oklahoma city uh this is
gonna be one of the
the most interesting off-season
questions because going into that game
last night
we were all kind of fixated on mike
d'antoni right would he be back with the
rockets next year billy donovan
coached the last game of his contract
with oklahoma city and you know sam
presti the thunder gm and donovan
have not sat down and spoke presti's
been on record saying he wants donovan
to come back but i think what it comes
down to
for billy donovan is what's the
direction of this team like this was
kind of
fool's gold this year that might be the
wrong phrase but like that nobody
expected this to
happen with oklahoma city i think billy
donovan wants to know
what's the plan here i mean this guy was
brought in back in 2015
to coach a team headlined by kevin
durant and russell westbrook now he's
coaching
a team without those two players and
it's very much unclear
what the thunder want to do they want to
tear this thing down and start a full
rebuild do they want to build off some
of these young players
and keep chris paul for the next couple
of years i think billy just wants some
clarity
on on what what the this team's future
is going to look like over the next
three or four years but he would be
he'd be a very interesting you know
coaching candidate on the free agent
market both for
the pro ranks where there's a few
openings still and even the college
ranks i mean he's one of the most
successful college coaches
of this century uh you know he would be
appealing to i think a lot of big-time
college programs oh before i let you go
we mentioned this earlier richard
jefferson the former nba player now an
analyst
said that uh greek freak is basically
scottie pippen and he needs himself a
michael jordan which
i thought there's not there's not a
bunch of michael jordan's out there
so i i'm not quite sure in fairness to
richard jefferson like does he have a
point here that
the greek freak is not your your alpha
and your 1a guy
not really i mean i i think that i think
before you can make that type
of assumption you have to get giannis
a running mate the equivalent of scottie
pippen don't you i mean
you know chris middleton's a good player
you know i had him third team all nba
this year at a guard spot but
if you look at the top tier teams in the
nba there's a big gap
between giannis is number two and
whether it's lebron's number two or
kawhi's number two or
uh you know some of these other you've
gotta i mean i think this is going to
turn out to be more
about giannis's supporting cast than
there's anything else if this team gets
beat
in the uh in the for in the second round
i do i do think a lot of it's on giannis
i mean
you can't turn the ball over like he did
in game one
you've got to make plays and frankly
don't answer questions like
you know if somebody asks you you know
do you want to play
every minute don't say i'm gonna leave
it up to my coach say you know if you
try to take me out of this game you know
what would jordan do what would kobe
they wouldn't let themselves be taken
out of these types of games so
i think johannes is gonna be a lot more
assertive uh moving forward but i
i mean it's a bit of a stretch to call a
guy it's gonna be a two-time mvp
you know a scottie pippen more than a
michael jordan good stuff chris you're
doing okay in the bubble
about my last few days here dan i'm
getting out on sunday
uh and i'm good with that i'm good
yeah you look you look like you're
it is like i mean it's one of these
experiences i'm going to write about
this a little bit on monday
like i wouldn't trade it for anything in
the world it's been probably the most
meaningful professional experience of my
life because of everything that's gone
on and really being able to document
history down here as it's played out
both with
you know competing in this covenant 19
era and what happened with the players
in the aftermath of the jacob blake
shooting but you when you're down here
you commit all day every day to the job
like i'm up 6 30 7 o'clock every morning
i get back from games 1 32 o'clock at
night it's every single day
and i don't have a problem with it but i
i wouldn't count on me surfacing for
more than
you know a couple of hours for the next
week or so when i get out of here pritzy
don't call mannix i should not yeah let
him let him kind of
decompress he likes my constant techs
all hours of the day yeah i'm sure he
does
i'm sure he doesn't know paulie tell
paulie to bring a couple you know little
maple syrup
over to vermont i'll be camped out up
there for the next week tall pack of bud
light oh
i like it hey that's that's a that's a
vermont beer spotlight
thanks thank you chris thank you chris
that's chris mannick sports illustrated
nba senior writer